l a tutti ragazzi e benvenute questo
momento sono fuori j oggi sia dall adisu
outlast 2 avevo provato ad aprire questa
porta era finito così l'altro episodio
ripresa che sta porta non si apre
ci sono delle porte di lato tipo questa
niente io che non si può terno anche
perché esce della luce che sciali però
non la puoi aprire il che fa un po
strano che bello entrare qui questi
fossero contento cazzo proprio bello
come andare a scuola lunedì mattina raga
fantastico la donna che brutto ambiente
mi chiamo potranno mettere due candele
maledizione attaccata al muro niente
tutto buio cazzola ho visto questo dato
è uscito sei proprio bello frate
ok però non credo sia a gesù cristo
finalmente prendi chiave prigione se
tipo una porta li devo andarmi calarti
mi chiedevo strisciare in mezzo alle
gabbie ragazzi lo sapevo lo sapevo lo
sapevo è inutile non mi sono preso il
colpo perché lo sapevo non mi tocchetti
de nunzio schifoso lurido comunque
ragazzi non vedo perché mia moglie debba
essere qua dentro c'è che razza di posto
verso perché c'è continuamente la foto
di padre sio propeso per ok permesso o
meno male perché credevo sarebbe ma
basta le foto di padre pio obeso tesoro
moglie cara non si sta roba che sta
facendo
aprite mag
che palle cazzo tesoro ha posto tesoro
si è atterrata sulle tue belle chiappone
[Musica]
ma perché non mi caga ma posso scendere
io li si può succederci posso credere
mai vai vai vai sono scesi sono ci sono
solo chelsea sono sceso prefetto tesoro
ciao mi chiamo ci posso credere di va
davvero
per ricaricare intesa locali carri come
quando arriva il titolo vuole farci
pagare il canone
vai vai veloce legge sorridi che
facciamo blog che facciamo le news non
mi tenere ok che sono una bella
coppietta vanno di tenere per mano in un
momento del genere corrie saranno le
cozze le cozze di ieri visto tavolo
detto che non devi mangiare
all'inizio le cose al limone troppe
perché sono porca eva e finire nei
manicomi abbandonati e finisce così
forman de panza cosa che hanno fatto
raga io mio cane
onesti
[Musica]
karimov il culo no c'è maledizione
perché dovrei stare fermi
muoviti muoviti prendila il braccio file
uomo porca eva è incinta ragazzi non
vedo un bene mi chiamare la compagnia
sta succedendo non si sa perché che mi
sta tenendo la gamba un albero cos'è una
roma labile chi è questo l'area prete
non mi far vedere sotto la gonna non
m'interessano io non mi macchia schifo
[ __ ] mani mora di tua sorella
brutto stronzo è vaga non ho parole
questo ma limonato la come si permette
come si ferma nco ma offerto un drink
prima ma limonato subito ma le buone
maniere dove sono
ecco fa ho appena finito di dirlo è
grazie albero della minkia raga quello
che mi sta tenendo la gamba un uomo
albero è un uomo albero pieno di sangue
non ha senso
a sori piedi è morta non l'ha portata
via
e morto alla portata via parquet ma cosa
è successo qua
sono ubriaca ragazzo ubriaco bucklaw per
quella scuola di arti sotto l'acqua
cominciando ma se mi hanno appena
lasciato lì lo sanno che arrivò già so
mica scemi dai forse potrebbero essere
dei [ __ ] effettivamente
bruttissimi dato york parquet va capita
nascosta sotto subito a giudicare dalla
musica forse mi hanno visto però non è
detto
emerge emergi ok sporcata feroce veloce
veloce sani sarà il deficiente perfetto
è corri corri corri demente corri non
trovo un errato
fosse successo dio santo perché ogni
tanto vitale trasporta in una scuola
qual è il problema però sto chiedendo
anch'io zio sappilo c'è un qualcosa che
suona ragazzi che non ho capito che
cos'è però cos'è ma chiesta agenda è
quella che stiamo molto a trovare mica
me l'ho dimenticato lo ha detto davvero
me l'ha detto davvero se appena
lamentato di essere tornata a scuola
avrebbe effettivamente tra la scuola e
autras c'è poco e di differenza feriali
ok
penso che stare in mezzo ai maniaci
fosse meglio che sarà scuola e che
effettivamente quindi è un pelato e ne
pare
è la madonna che spallata mai dato cazzo
sei problema ma chi è sta gente ma
perché sto sognando ma riesce grazie a
dio posso uscire a questo è il paradiso
ragazzi sono uscito la scuola wow
porca [ __ ] e niente dove mica son
caduto ragazzi dell'inferno dove adesso
una ragazza di omc piazza ma stavo
sognando no non ho capito florio maran
si mangiava ethan synth humour skip face
questo farà una brutta fine
io ve lo dico io lo so me lo sento
i casi importante che ethan che è un
uomo che si pulisce la faccia la mattina
ci porti razzismo rapidissimi stories
quindi tu vivi quasi che bello come ci
vai all esselunga per fare la spesa
perché non lo voglio saperlo io li
chiudi per l'amor di dio chiudi st porta
porca eva curami trio curami già fa
schifo sta a casa ci manca solo che
debba andar lì sotto anche tomic e
accoglienza azione il suo ex click su ok
grazie ma posso dormire nelle bello
questo letto bene ma proprio bello
comodo
sicuramente mi sveglio che vedo qualcosa
che succede nel
di sopra perché si vede attraverso le
tegole ho giocati tanti horror che lo so
io le sono le cose lo so lo sapevo lo
sapevo che c'è qualcuno sapevo che un
papa sky sport ma questo esile ma che
avevano applicazione è chiaro perché li
metto tutto su youtube
io faccio le views fit belt cioè dal
titolo amico viene picchiato ma è un po
grossa st donna ha preso fuori prima che
mi serviva a quale altro episodio praga
mica facciamo le views sto riprendendo
tutto con questa donna quest
proporzionata laga troppo grossa io
l'avevo detto e questo non c'è una
brutta fine
in realtà credevo sarebbe durato qualche
episodi più però non è durato tantissimo
ai maya non lo fare non lo fare non lo
fare
ho visto forse faceva male
ok
beh dai ho visto giornata iniziare
peggio di questo tipo quando hai tre
verifiche in un giorno solo
va bene rimuovi l'attore ok grazie amico
mio che mi hanno protetto
se sei un vero amico vero
posso uscire da in una bruttissima c'era
pensavo peggio
posso andare di qua te che minchia siamo
ragazzi il posto brutto e questo a praga
dove mi chiama o e la tipa di prima no
non è la tipa di prima
la sta leggendo mi chiama che basteranno
insta discoteca non sto capendo sul
serio sapete quanto rido seccate mica
quanto rido se crolla al pompili
mandandoti stancheremo altro rifugio ha
capito mica far uscire perché non so
dove stiamo andando maiolo jolo di qua
tua madre porta di gonorrea ricorda che
poi sarà il microfono
sì lo sto facendo con questo il video
premendo un microfono d'arancia maghi
cosa
ok ma lercio lo sapevo è una situazione
un po una merda le donne donne gravide
saranno scortate grazie dio
ovvio cosa è successo e mia moglie è
quella non è mia moglie grazie a dio c'è
gente non c'è un pertugio però eccolo
perfetto che ho trovato subito veloce
però prima che arrivino salve
buona giornata anche lei non so io che
l'errore di uno scherzo torri e demente
corri euro per quanto tempo no vabbè
ragazzi di pericolo
corre lap dance lap dance dove vado a
iniziava caparra che non riescono e che
è sì allora poi la schiaffeggia tua
madre brutto pervertito saia
secondo me sono morto però non è detto
ma lavori scostò pertugio vi capitolo
prima maledizione
ok capi qua poi arriva il tizio porchera
che ansia ma che ansia
minchia stiamo andando e cactus schifoso
infame per te solo catrame a devo andare
qua sopra procedente lì quindi occorre
loro carri male dentro e vabbè falso
tempo è ma perche madonna forlì come mia
nonna
ok a posto quello non so a scavalcare
meno male che minchione però forse c'è
qualcun altro che lo store cazzo è una
interrogazione sicuro ma non è che share
later rincoglionito se mi tocchi arriva
uno chef che ti gira la testa
bene cazzi tuoi e importante che porcava
quello che il punto la torcia attraverso
le pannocchie meno male ke ha è quella
dove è passata la tipa di prima perciò
sono proprio contento netta di questa
direzione stato contentissimo a salve
che bella quella cosa che hai in mano a
chi cazzo ti vuole continua a cantare
tranquillissimo drunk tranquilli
tranquilli olio cammino vado mi tolgo
dalle palle perfette c'entra il progetto
fatemi entrare vi prego dio gesù a dario
posso nascondermi dietro al bidone con
loro davanti sarà non credo mi serva a
qualcosa che sarà quindi più di più di
fare qualche chiudi non si può chiudere
meno e meno male io si può chiudere
meno male rispetto all e c'è anche il
bookie 94
non è stata una gara vive a ok bye bye
bye ignorati dai [ __ ] bye bye bye
perfetto fuori fuori ok
jesus anche l'ansia di questo videogioco
credibile deve andare lassù
vai vai veloce veloce zio prima cari
bello veloce che torna veloce e veloce
perfetto ok
vorrei sapere se fosse questo cazzo
scegliendo questa porta ma è meglio non
saperlo ma non è vero che tira a ti
senti non si apre la porta io io l'ho
anche detto io magari è mera meglio
evitare per hobby piedi zia dei piedi
riescono a volte non riesco anche a
commentare le cose perché fanno
veramente schifo
eva buried possono mai buttarmi su un
putridume di cadaveri e sempre una
giornata di merda quando un cadavere ti
colpisce in pieno il volto è sempre come
una brutta giornata muovono questo
fegato è il protagonista il suo gioco
una volta una volta era vegano poi poi
poi è morto direttamente sicuro è un
altoparlante
[Musica]
ma riesco perché su caduti piccioni cosa
è successo vuoi è partito il drop di
martin garics sugli altoparlanti troppo
forte sono passati dal simbolo la hall
si cade va bene che mia moglie e mia
moglie ho visto segnando tutto chi è
[Musica]
ma gag ma perché spariscono i cadaveri
ma che figata cioè figata fino a un
certo punto perché sono cadaveri e na
figata se iniziano essere persone vive
un po meno
va bene la cappella una cappella e un
altro zio grave devo arrivare alla
cappella io per forza porca [ __ ] non
so scendere dalle dei posti io non so
scendere dai posti mettete delle fottute
scale per il prossimo outlast anzi non
lo fate il prossimo al da se possibile
grazie contento in regola volevo bello
ok perfetto
si prova o che non vale la cantina oddio
mi chiami sembrava la maschera
dell'enigmista sarebbe stato troppo figo
c'è nessuno oh che bello finchè c'è
gente morta io vi ripeto per me non è un
problema di riportate che rimanga morta
brutto questo paese ma quello ancora che
mi cerca ma basta posso scendere senza
morire maledizione ogni volta che scendo
da qualcosa grazie che alimenta nella
persecuzione rai a quello potrebbe
essere un ascensore
mi piaceva ci manca solo questo guardia
ci mancava l'importante che
checa ha aperto la porta
salve oddio quella è la tipo di prima
che predicava sul torrente fantastico ma
si è aperta si è chiuso st porta o salve
anche all'euro tesoro sentimi ma c'è una
che sta mangiando una pannocchia è una
challenge mangiare la pannocchia senza
mani e poi fate il video il registro è
facciamo le views o cristo anno non
manca gato 10 specie odio normale che
non mi tocca sta gente di casa non ero
nella merda la madonna con ricordi pace
caricari velocissimo velocissimo e vabbè
accordo ragazzi capisce anche il secondo
episodio di outlast 2 spero di vedervi
nel terzo terzo episodio esce lunedì
questo che arriva quindi non vi
preoccupate che non ci metto tanto a
farlo quindi la che sono lì spero che vi
sia piaciuto come senza che il momento è
un mi piace anche marie social capito
iscrizione cinesi di scrittrici vediamo
un po servito da ragazzi
[Musica]